greetings and welcome to coding tech's
youtube channel
i'm your host michael j griffin jr and i
will be walking you through this d3
basics tutorial
without further ado let's get started
all right
so let's take a look at what we'll
actually be building uh this is a basic
web app that connects to the movie
databases uh api
grabs the new releases for a given year
and a genre
uh you know prints out the uh or gives
links to the um
to the months of the year and allows you
to view
new releases uh for that month okay you
can go back to the top
you can change the year 2012 here uh
let's go october 2012 right go back to
the top
you can see certain fields that we
selected the title release date vote
count vote averaging genres
again you can select any of those fields
as we go through this you'll get a
chance to see what the data looks like
and what you'd like to pull back but
without further ado again let's
get right into building this and let's
take a look at the concepts
that we're going to cover all right so
our basic outline is we're going to talk
about what
technologies we're using uh we're going
to do a basic setup of the document and
the project we're going to do some basic
dom manipulation
we're going to connect to the third
party api then we'll do a little bit
more advanced or intermediate dom
manipulation
and then we'll have some concluding
thoughts uh future vision for
uh these tutorials and we'll show you
how to get to the code
um you know in the the repository that
we've set up so
let's talk about we're going to use
right we're going to be using d3js
all right data driven documents let's
click that link and just show you what
that is
right it's just a javascript library for
manipulating documents based on data
right the power
power of d3 actually comes when you
start to use it
um you know creating charts and and
visualization
things of that nature now we're going to
we're not going to do that with this
video
we're going to have those are going to
be future videos but stick with us we're
just trying to get some basics out of
the way now so that we can
build you up so that you'll be able to
take d3
uh to the next level all right then
we're also going to be using visual
studio code
you can choose you can choose whatever
code editor you want
but this is the one that we'll be using
uh someone that i'm most familiar with
so
that's the one i'm using and then
bootstrap now bootstrap you know there's
a lot of pros and cons to using
bootstrap but again because we're going
to be using this as a basic app
that just needs some basic styling and
we're not putting it out there
for consumption for the you know for the
world to see bootstrap is just going to
help us to get
you know something that actually looks
decent all right so those are the three
technologies that we're going to focus
on
i want to close those real quick and
then we'll get started
building the project okay so first thing
we're gonna do
is create our first file all right so
let's let's create it
index.html and actually you'll be able
to see just i created this preview
so that we can walk through this
together right uh
i'll keep this over here so that you can
see it and you'll be able to say okay
well this is where we're headed next
right
uh you'll be able to track along with me
all right so i'm gonna use emmet
uh and i'm gonna just type in html of
colon
colon five and it creates an html
document for me
if you don't know what image is i
suggest you know you just click over
here to the
plugins type in emmet and install it
right uh so yeah so that would be
something that would be very beneficial
for you as a developer
especially if you're working in html
it's a very helpful plug-in
okay so let's next let's get our
bootstrap
all right we're going to click that link
there all right and you see we've got
the
yeah so this is what we want we want the
css we're going to go over here
into the head of the uh document sorry
and we're going to do a link
real equal sorry rail equals
style sheet and we're going to give it
an href
of that oh sorry i need to go back here
and copy it again
all right there we go all right all
right and we'll close that
so now we've got our basic style sheets
set up
all right the next thing we need to do
is install d3 so i'm going to click that
here and i'm going to grab this script
tag
all right we're going to copy it and
bring it into our document at the
end of the body tag here all right
okay so we've got installed bootstrap
right so we're on
step four we've installed bootstrap
we've installed uh d3
we've created our basic html document
now there are three
uh uh four more steps left but the three
files that i want to create
so i'm just gonna come over here open up
oh you can click command b
or yeah you just click that there right
either there or you can click yeah comma
shift command e to get that all right so
let's just
but i want to create here a main
sorry api key let's call it api key dot
js because this is going to
uh hold our api key
the key that we get sorry that we get
from uh yeah from the movie database all
right
so we'll we'll leave that file there all
right we're going to create another file
here called main.js
we'll leave that there and then we'll
create another file called main.css
which will house some specific styling
and mostly i'm just going to copy and
paste that in here now
because this is not really a styling
tutorial css tutorial
uh but i'm just going to copy and paste
that stuff in here so you don't have to
really focus on that
alright so i see down here the last
thing we're going to do for this section
is to create
an iffy right and if you know what an
iffy is there's an immediately invoked
functional expression expression and i
have that spelled wrong
so you get to see me uh fix a mistake
here oh
there it is right so i have it i have it
there right but here it's wrong
all right so we go back and it should be
correct there we go we're going to set
up an iffy right
so niffy is an immediately invoked
function expression
all right so this is basically what it
is all right
and we're gonna do that sorry okay
so that's all that is right in the
main.js we're just setting that up
okay so that is the end of this section
we're gonna move on next
to dom manipulation all right
all right we're back with the dom
manipulation section
okay so we've got our main js here and
we've got our iffy setup
let's go back to our index.html and
bring that
in okay so we're going to do a script
tag
the source is main dot js
and we're going to close that off okay
so now we've got access to our main js
inside of our html page okay
so what we're going to do next is we've
got to uh pull in some dependencies
okay so one of the things that uh that
we'll have here when we import this
d3.js is we'll have a d3 object that we
can use to manipulate the dom
all right so we've got to get that d3
object into our main js so we can use it
inside of our iffy all right so that the
easiest way to do that
is to call d3 here and then in
in our um in our iffy here we're just
going to call it uh d3 so this is
basically the idea is dependency
injection
all right so we have this d3 object we
want to use it inside of here we want to
make sure that we're not colliding with
anything else
so we use this dollar sign d3 it's a
common practice you'll see it
um in angular you'll see it in uh
jquery uses it many multiple multiple
places all over the internet right
uh so now we've got our d3
object inside of our
iffy all right so now we can start
manipulating the dom all right
so we're going to set up our main
container
all right this is going to be the
container that allowed that um that
we're going to start off with that we're
going to inject
everything into our application all
right
so without further ado let's get right
to that all right so we're going to
create that we're going to call it const
sorry const main container
and we're going to use d3 right to
append
i'm sorry d3 we're going to uh select
so this is something you'll get used to
like d3 has a select this is how you
select
um uh it's the selector method for d3
right
so if you're used to um if you used to
basic dom manipulation or jquery is very
similar to that
uh you select the body so we're going to
basically be selecting the body tag
right and we're going to say i want to
append to that body tag
so this is how we put something inject
something inside of that body tag
we're going to call we're going to say i
want to um inject
a div and then i want to give it some
attributes all right so the first
attribute i want to give it is
main container and then i also want to
give it uh the attribute
of class and the value of
container all right so that's not really
going to do anything we won't see
anything
now one thing i want to do is real quick
is i want to
highlight something that i'm going to
use to help us to see this
as we're developing and it's called live
server okay let me make sure that live
server is
up and i'm going to come over here
live server if you need that yeah
so if you need that you just come over
here and you install it it's already
installed in mine
uh so basically i think i probably just
need to uh
reload and live server should probably
come up so i'm going to reload the
project
and i want to see if it uh if it
displays here hold on one second
all right there it is and it's going to
come up it says go live so i'm going to
click that and it's going to start up a
live server
for me so it's saying one port is
already taken so it's going to try to
use another one
and you'll see that uh the document
that's right so there's absolutely
nothing going on here right
i just opened up the um the terminal
uh the console so i could see but
there's absolutely nothing going on here
because i don't have any code in there
right so let's keep going all right
let's keep going i'm going to actually
bring this back over here let me close
these two
all right and i'm going to do i'm going
to make the preview
available again and where were we we
were right here dom
uh dom manipulation okay so we got our
we got our main container set up we're
going to set up our basic document
structure now i'm not going to go
through
each and every uh line of code because
that would take a while
but i'm going to explain it as i copy
and paste it in here all right
so the main container that i just set up
i want an append in h1
with the id of top and the text of t uh
tmdb new releases so if i go back over
here that's what i should see right
tmdb new releases all right so there's
something that's going on that's a
little bit different than what we see
here
right so if i were to let me grab this
and
yeah so let me show this over here all
right so
yeah all right let's do that all right
so we'll see that this is a
little bit different than what we've got
going on over here
so something's wrong right all right so
we're looking at them and we're like oh
what something's happening
i'll tell you what's what's wrong i'll
give you uh
you know a hint but the reason that it's
not showing up is that i don't have that
main css
uh linked here all right so that's the
issue all right so remember i created
that
uh the file right here the main css
and i put all of those styles in there i
just need to
copy and paste that and bring it into uh
oops sorry uh yeah let me copy and paste
that
and bring that into it and now we see
we've got it centered
and in its proper place all right so
let's keep going
all right so we've got our basic
document structure i've created the
header
all right so i'm going to create the
year the year select list and
the genre select list and then the years
links div
okay and that should actually read genre
select list right there
right so let's actually pull this in and
we'll say all right
genre there we go all right so you get
to see the
the live updates and edits all right
so we got year select list and genre
select list so we've got our header and
now we need to use d3
to pull in that other information all
right let me get that out of the way
okay so we got our main container there
let's get let's pull in some code
all right so i'm actually going to
create a div
right here what this is doing is
creating the options div
right beneath the so if you look at this
right beneath the header i want this div
that's gonna uh
span across and put where i can put in
both
of the the year and the genre okay uh so
that's that option div and then in that
option div
i'm going to create two more divs right
so you see the same
the same pattern right i have a
container if i want to append something
to it
right i just use the append method and
then
on that node i can put any attributes or
anything that i want so i've got i'm
putting attribute of id on it
on this one attribute of year attribute
of genre right so these are the
divs that i'm actually creating all
right so now
let me show you the months div so this
is all the basic basic
structure right so the month divs right
we've got this main container
um we're in the main container again i
want to create the month divs
so that's basically this right here
right this
list of months okay so that's what i'm
looking at so i'm going just div by div
so i've got this div
and i put two divs in it right and then
i've got this div and i'm putting some
other divs in it right
so this is the movie data div so this is
the one that the
that is all of this stuff here right so
this is the movie data dave i'm creating
that one as well
so you've got to create all of those
right now what you could have done you
obviously didn't have to go through d3
to do all of this you could have just
created those
uh in html and then injected
uh your d3 dynamic
uh divs in those right but i just wanted
to go ahead and show you
this is basically how you go about doing
that right you create your div and then
you append anything that you want to add
to it
so you're basically creating a hierarchy
of a document all right
so let's create this year select list
okay all right so i'm going to copy some
code over here and then i'll explain it
to you
uh explain what we're doing here all
right now this is going to be a nice
little dump of code right i'm just gonna
dump it in there all right
and we're gonna break some things as
well but we'll fix it as we go along
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna get rid of
this uh
right because that's coming later okay
but
i created in the year div i'm saying
okay give me a label
right with the class of select label and
the text of select
year okay all right so that's basically
creating this
okay so if we were to go back here you'd
see it right yeah
all right so that's what we're creating
okay all right so that's what this
creates and then we're going to take
that year div
we're going to append a select tag to it
we're going to give it the idea of your
select and then we're going to create an
event handler
so whenever this changes i want to call
this function
okay and then what's going to happen is
i'm going to get the current genre which
we haven't created yet
i want to get the value of the current
genre and the value of the current year
and then i want to call my get movie
data for year function
all right which i haven't created yet
okay but we're going to create that in a
little bit
all right so then we're going to take
this year select
and then we're going to add a bunch of
options to it now all we need to really
add
is a range of years all right so that's
what we've got to do
right you see i've got this created
already but let's go ahead and show you
what that
is it's basically and i the idea is to
create a list of years from 2020 to
uh 1950 in reverse order that's what
this is that's what this is doing right
and then we're going to get inside we're
going to use the enter method
to iterate through all of those years
and for each one of those years we're
going to append
an option tag to the select option
to the select list all right with the
text and we're telling it okay we'll get
the text
by calling this function and the
function is basically just going to
return the value
of whatever came from the data okay all
right that's all it's doing
okay so let's try that all right so i'm
gonna i'm gonna uh paste in that range
of years function that i created all
right and we'll put it at the top
um yeah we'll put it at the top of the
method here right so all it does is just
say okay
give me a start and then end date and
then create an array
from end um you know of length
uh end minus star plus one then fill it
all right and then map over that
creating the
um creating year plus index right and
the idea is you're just getting
2001 2020 to 1950 and that's all that's
you know based on what you put in there
right so the mid-year match year that
that was decided by me
it really didn't have to be um and i'll
just show you how i came about
i just said okay this is the main year
this is the max year 1950
to the whatever date your uh whatever
date you run this so next year if you
run this it'll be 2021
right all right so that's what we're
getting right that's what we're getting
when we do that
okay all right so instead of having to
explain all that right so it's like oh
okay yeah this is this is working
great all right so then we need to get
that genre list
all right so let's create that genre
list i'm going to pull in some code that
does that as well and it's going to be
extremely similar all right so it's very
similar to what we did
the only issue the only difference and
i'll get rid of this really quickly
um the only difference is that we're
going to pull the genres
from the genre list uh
at the movie database and i'll show you
how to uh i'll just copy and paste that
but now i'll show you the link later on
where i went to
to get that information right all right
but you'll see that this is very similar
okay uh and actually i probably should
change that
there you go to select label and now
right so we got the genre list
it does nothing it doesn't have anything
in it but you'll see here
that there's a dependency that i
injected to get that information right
so i'm actually going to create now a
list
file all right let's go over here and
create a file called
lists.js all right and that list.js
is going to give us a bunch of uh
interesting information but the first
one we're going to pull in
is the genres right so i'm going to
paste those in and these are the
uh the genres directly from the movie
database
so i figured instead of calling the
database for that these don't really
change that often let's just pull them
in
and work with them okay all right so
this
is going to need to be injected but we
first
we've got to say okay well i've got this
now let me pull in this
lists right and now list is available to
us
but we don't want to just have it you
know hanging out let's do this let's
just say okay we're gonna
let's pull that john ross all right and
let's see um let's see and then we'll
call it genres
okay so now we should be able to go over
and we see
our genres right so we've got our genres
first we're going to start off with
nothing
right because we wanted to pull
everything regardless of genre but then
you can select
right you'll see oh this is you know all
right so
we've got our we've done our header
we've created our select year list
we've created our genre select list now
we need to create our years
links div all right and then we'll be
done with basic dom manipulation and
we'll go and get some actual
data from this bad boy all right so
well actually you know what let's
actually do that uh we've created our
year's links div what we'll do is we'll
start building the function
in the next section after we do our
third party api connection so we want to
do that
then we'll show you how to create those
years at the top right so
we'll do this next okay yeah we'll show
you how to create these
uh based on you know whatever data we
get
okay cool let's do that in the next
section
all right welcome back now we're going
to connect to the third party api and
that's
the movie database so let's click that
link all right
so this is the movie database right well
it says welcome millions of movie tv
shows and people
to discover explore now so you can
search here or you can sign up for a
developer account
i've already signed up for one all right
you can click here
uh you go to settings and then here you
click
api and you would uh sign up for an api
key
once you have it you'll copy that and
you'll bring it into your
application remember i created the um
yeah the api key.js and i gave you that
string all you would do is copy and
paste
your api key into that string and you'll
be good to go
all right so that is going to be the end
for this section
it's fairly simple right we're gonna
move on into the next section which will
be
dom manipulation and we'll get more uh
advanced
uh we'll start working with tables and
data and all that other stuff all right
see y'all in the next section
all right let's get right back into it
because this is the
longest section of the video okay so
we're going to fill our genre list or
i'm just going to show you where i was
able to go to
get that genre list because we've
already filled it so i just click that
click this button here click that link
there and i'll show you this is where i
got that information from
it's from the developers um link
on the movie database you just go into
you click try it out
you enter your api key click send
request and it'll give you that list
all right and that list is what i'm
using uh in my lists
over here right you'll see these are
it's the same
exact data right so i think instead of
calling again we'll just use this list
because it's pretty static all right
so let's get back to creating the
function that's the next thing we're
going to do
and the function that i'm talking about
is this one right here where uh the get
movie data for year okay
so i don't have that function and i've
already created the uh event handlers
right you'll see there
um i've already created those event
handlers but i don't have the function
so let's create the function
all right so i'm going to bring that
over here let's say const to get
movie data for year i'm going to give it
a year and give it a genre
and i'm going to create it's going to be
an arrow function so now that
error should go away okay so
we're going to clear the divs that's the
fourth thing we're going to clear the
divs on each column what divs am i
talking about all right
so the divs that i'm talking about are
the two divs that house the information
okay so
the months div and i'll show you which
one that is
that's let's go back to the top that's
this one all right we're going to clear
that div
and we're going to clear the movie data
div which is that one
all right so i'm going on every
iteration
or every time i change uh one of these
i want to get rid of all of that data
below it okay
uh it makes sense right because you
don't want that same data
being populated you don't want to just
dump more data on top of it you want it
just for that
specific year and for the genre that you
selected all right
so again and for our change our change
handlers we're just getting
you know we're using basic uh git
element diet but
by id and the value of that
element all right and that's what we're
getting as the genre and the year all
right
so that's your value that you're
returning here and that's basically
all all she wrote right so if you do
value a different attribute
for value then you you can return
something else otherwise it's just going
to return
the same thing right now she can get rid
of that all right that was two texts it
didn't need to be called twice
okay all right so the value uh is
necessary for the genre but not really
for the year because the year is going
to be 2020 that's what it is
okay so we're clearing those the next
thing we need to need to do is create
those month
links all right that we see here month
links okay
so i'm going to just paste some code in
here that does that for us
now you'll see that i'm injecting
something here so i need to go and get
it
all right so i'm going to inject the
month list
i'm going to pull that in and it's
really basic it's just
a list of all the months all right
january through
december okay no big deal all right but
over here i just want to inject it uh
just in case
right we we decide we want to send
something else i don't know maybe the
month will change
sometime soon who knows right this 2020
man who knows what's gonna change right
so uh so we're gonna get those month
divs and we're going to say okay
select select all divs create them
based on these months iterate through
the the data in the months
append and anchor with the class of
month name
and the hyper ref will be to
uh the month name which will be january
and whatever year we're on so if it's
january it'll be january
2020 and it'll create 12 of those okay
so let's see if it actually does it uh i
was having some problems
with it reloading um the hot loader
for yeah the hot loader for
uh live server was giving me some
trouble so
uh maybe maybe not all right so man
you know why i know why it's not working
all right because i didn't call it
all right you got to call a function if
you want it to work right
okay all right so that's kind of that's
kind of uh
programming 101 right you want your
function to work you got
someone to do uh let's see i'm gonna say
genres
sub zero the first one dot id
let's see what happens hey it works all
right so we got links to nowhere
all right so it's accuracy is up there
it's actually working we got links to
nowhere all right
excellent so if we change this it'll
change it
we should see january 2010 perfect all
right so
all's good all right so animation comedy
blah blah blah all right we good
all right we are good okay so we created
our month links now
this is where it gets really fun okay
so we've got to get some data from
the api all right now
i did a lot of you know i did a lot of
working through this so you don't have
to
um i went into the uh the documentation
found what works where
i left some links up here for those of
you who actually want to do that
you can click on these links getting
started or discovery
dash you know movie discover or the
documentation itself
and just walk through what discover
gives you so you can do all of that
information you can do that on your own
time but as we're walking through this
video i figured you know the video will
get extremely long if we try to explain
all of that stuff
so you're just gonna have to trust me
all right so i'll just all right so
before we get to that we've got to do a
couple of other things okay
so before to be good citizens we want to
make sure
that whenever we are calling out to the
api we give the user some indication
that something's happening
so that they're just not sitting there
waiting for something to happen so i
wanted to create a loader all right
and you'll see this prcs loaders right
actually had the link already up
all right and i chose this one i chose
the facebook
um it's called the lds facebook all
right so i copied this css into my css
and then i used all right and i'll show
you the function that i wrote to create
this
but i used you know whatever they said
right you have to create one div
and it has to be the parent of three
other divs right
all right so that's basically what i did
right i used i created a function
that does exactly that so instead of and
i made it dry
so you know don't repeat yourself all
right so i'm going to put that function
up here
all right so create loading animation
all right
all right and i'm going to say okay well
look let me get let me pick that all
right
so i'm going to use d3 to create a div
put the attribute class of lds
facebook and then inside of that i want
to append three divs
all right so load the animation i'm
going to pin three extra divs
and then i return that okay so now every
time
i go into uh the call to say okay i want
to get
data out of the api i'm going to show
that
i'm going to show that loading animation
all right so let's show you how that's
actually going to work now
i'm going to do a little cleanup i'm
sorry a little bit of code i'm going to
copy this code in and i'll explain what
it does
all right so this is an asynchronous for
each basically it's going
to give us the ability to call
asynchronous functions
uh in a loop all right and i'll show you
why that's important okay so
all right so we're going to get the data
for each month let's go down here
and inside of our function after we get
the month month divs we're going to get
data for each month
uh and we're going to do this all right
so that's we're going to call this
for every month in our list of months
we're going to call we're going to call
this function okay
all right let me just close that off
because that's actually let me
make sure that there are no oh yeah we
got to make this asynchronous
all right you saw that error down here
it was giving me the little squiggly
saying hey you got to make me a saying
if you want to use a weight you got to
make the function asynchronous all right
so i'm going to call our async
for each go through each element in the
months
and we're going to run
code for that month all right so let's
do this we're going to do a try catch
because we want to be good citizens just
in case something breaks the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to append that loading
right the loading oh sorry first thing
we got to do
is we got to get we got an append append
a div
to the movie data all right so for each
one of these i'm going to append a new
div right and i probably could have
moved that
down there yeah all right so we're going
to append a new div
to the uh the movie data div right and
that div
we're just going to that div we're going
to append the
the loading animation okay so if i were
to go back
you'll see it there right look at that
isn't it pretty
right it's just random loading divs like
12 of them
okay we could just stop right there no
we can't stop right there this is
useless
let's keep going all right so so let's
uh so this is where it's going to get
well you got to trust me okay i'm going
to copy something in here
it's gonna be you know kinda long but
i'll explain what it's doing
all right so i'm going out to the movie
database using the discovery link
getting uh
movies use calling my api with my api
key
i'm saying okay if i have a genre so if
you pass me a genre in here
right then append the genre
to the query string otherwise do nothing
don't don't append anything
and then i want everything from the us
region with release type new release
or yeah and primary release date is
going to be
greater than or equal to the first day
of the month and
less than or equal to the last day of
the month that's all that
this is doing right all this stuff down
here right and basically uh this part is
saying if there's a if it's a one digit
uh for one digit number then append a
zero to the front of it that's all
that's that's all that little slice
things doing right there with the
slicing
yeah all right so that's basically what
that's doing it's going out and it's
getting
some you know well it's it's creating a
url
d3 is going to actually go out and get
the data for us now this is the cool
thing about d3
we don't have to add anything else we
don't need axios we don't need requests
we don't need fs we don't need anything
like that
all right no super agent any of that all
right so we'll just go out here and we
say hey d3 go get me json from this
uh right from this link and let's just
see what d3 does
right d3 is pretty cool it says i i got
you
i'm gonna take care of this all right so
movie data all right let's see what
happens all right i'm gonna open up my
terminal
all right i'm gonna refresh that and see
what happens all right so
uh that nothing happened all right i
don't like when nothing happens all
right let's see what happens
all right there is there an error that's
happening let me display
any errors that come through i'm going
to put my error
um yeah uh that's one of the reasons why
i put i brought this i kept this up
because i want to use that same
div all right now i remember all right
so error retrieving
data oh boy all right so what's the
error
oh you might want to tell me console
let's see what the error is
all right oops all right what's the
error let's do that
error all right what's the error
oh api key is not defined
all right well we got to define that api
key let's do
all right so the way we're going to do
that is we got to just call it right
so that's part of the reason why it i
never included it
all right so api key is right here all
right
so now you see we're getting data okay
now our loading's still over there but
at least we're getting data back okay
so we get one page with the results uh
you know
array we're just getting 20 at a time
you'll see let me bump that up a little
bit
there you go i'll bump that up a little
bit so you can see it all right so you
got your backdrop path you got your
genre ids you got your id for the movie
uh you got your english there's original
language you got your original title for
the movie
all right the overview uh you got some
pretty good information right title
video what you know what type of video
it is or if it's video
of we have a video for it uh the vote
average and the vote count
okay and it's popular popularity score
all right so we've got some good
information here
so let's try to use some of this
information and
uh make something better than these
loading images
all right so let's do that all right let
me close this out
and let's go back okay so let's go back
to our main
so now that we've got movie data we can
get rid of that all right so let's start
building
something more substantial okay now
the i'm gonna i'm gonna paste some stuff
in here that
you're just gonna have to trust me again
you're doing a lot of trusting me but
that's fine
right so we're gonna once we get movie
data that's we want to get rid of all
those loading
images right uh so each one of them does
that all right
so i'm gonna put the information in here
that actually builds
the top level of this section i'll show
you what i'm talking about
this section up here for each one of
them i don't think that that's really
you know that's something that's not
really um
that's not really earth shattering based
on the stuff that we've already done
all right uh let's see fill to the
source map
all right there we go so we've got that
january 2020 and top
right uh yeah if we click that we'll go
back to the top all right
so that stuff that's really you know you
can you can decipher through that right
it's just a pending divs and all that
stuff right you we've we did that in the
beginning this is just more repetition
of that same thing
all right but the cool thing is when we
get we start creating the table all
right so i'm going to create the basic
table right
uh let's see uh let's put that in create
table data table
all right so we have a table we're gonna
put it inside of the month div gonna pin
the table with the class table
and the um so that's this is a bootstrap
class
and this is my personal class which kind
of uh sets the width and stuff like that
okay so we are pinned in a table now you
see that everything kind of goes
you know it spreads out right so that
table is actually helping us to do that
now
this is something that uh again you're
gonna have to trust me on this one
all right so we don't want all of the
data showing up right we got a lot of
data back
that wasn't stuff that we're gonna use
we're gonna we're gonna focus on just
the title the release date the votes
count vote
count vote average and the genres okay
so let's let's uh this is what we're
going to do
all right so we're going to set up
another list
of all the fields that we want all right
so i'm going to go into list
and we're going to say these are the
desired headers i want title
release date vote count vote average and
the genre ids
that's what i want okay and i'm going to
come in here and say okay well this is
what i want so let me do
desired headers
and i will call this up here i will say
i'm injecting the headers in there
headers all right so now
for my filtered movie data i'm going to
say well look
so go through the movie data that we get
from the movie database
the results that we get from it i want
to take the headers
that i created right that's this list
titled
all the way through genre ids we're
going to do a call reduce
and this is our accumulator and this is
the current one we're on and we'll say
okay we're saying for the accumulator
sub current that's basically saying
for movie data uh the accumulator is
this
right so for this object basically tell
give me the um
sorry give me the current um property
that's at this one set the current
property of the accumulator
equal to the data that we got that same
field from the accumulator
so it's basically it's just filtering
out all of the data that we don't want
and then it's returning the accumulated
value so it's always gonna
i'll show you what happens right i'll
just console.log it right instead of
explaining it right we'll just console
log it
right so this now you don't have to do
this this is based on this is your this
decision as to what you whether or not
you want to do it but
you can get all of the data you can do
you can do whatever you want um
but for our purposes i wanted just those
five fields so genre id
release date title vote average and vote
count now you see that's the one two
three four
five those are the five fields that i
want those are the five fields that i'm
going to grab back
right so now that i have those five
fields in
um an array of objects
now i'm going to go through and create
the table right i didn't want to create
the table with all of that data
i basically just wanted to create uh the
table
with with the fields that i wanted all
right so let me show you what i'm doing
now next i'm gonna just create i'm gonna
show you how to create the table headers
right so we take that same table that we
created up here
and we're gonna pin the table head and
then to that we're gonna pin the table
row
and then we're going to select or create
uh the table header
uh you know field or cell and then we're
going to go through and look at
all of the headers that we created right
the header list that we have
i'm going to iterate through all of them
with the enter method append a th to
each one of those
and for the text i just want to take uh
the the actual data that i got from
headers
which in this case would be title
release date vote count
that that's the data and i want to say
you know what
give me the ac
if it's not genre ids if it's genre ids
just change it to genres because i don't
want to show genre ids right
um but if it's not that then just
replace the underscore
with a space right if it has one so
that's how we're getting
this right and then i'm using css to
transform the text
so that it's capitalized i'm sorry it's
all uppercase
yeah it's all uppercase all right so
that's how i'm doing that
uh nothing magical uh just you know
that's what that that's what this class
is so if you go to movie tablehead
in the uh in the main.css you will see
yeah you'll see text transform uppercase
right that's all it's doing right
so instead of me having to do all of
that in javascript i'll let css handle a
little bit of work right
we want to um we want to be even-handed
and how much we get how much data we
give to each thing
all right so let's keep moving right
along all right so we've got our head
our headers now let's add our data now
the data is going to be a little bit
more complex
uh i'll probably get we could probably
get away with removing some of this but
i want to do this at least
i'm going to grab up to this point
i'm going to pull this in i'm going to
say this is my table data
all right so for each one i'm going to
say append
on the table append for the table append
the table body
right table body tag uh create
tr select all the tr's use the filtered
movie data that we created
uh iterate through all of it append the
new tdr
select all tds right so this is like
this is how you're getting through
in d3 how you're understanding what you
know what it does or how it manages and
manipulates the dom
so for each data uh each data that a
data point that we get back
i basically want to map through all of
them right
map through everything that we've got uh
and
return an array of all of those data
points and then iterate through those
and create data td or table
data cells for each one all right
and then on that i want to create uh i
want to
give it the attribute of class movie
table body all right
and then the last last but not least
i need to tell it what i want to show
because right now it's doing nothing
right
if i did that i left it there yeah it
gave me all 20 of those rows
but there's no text in it all right but
the last thing we need to do is tell it
well what what do you want to pull
well i actually want to pull if the
headers
um the indexes headers.length minus one
if the last one basically if this is the
last one if it's genres
all right if it's genres i want to go
through and i want to uh do a map
um so i'm gonna map on all map over all
of those the the genre
array i want to say okay look give me
all the genres
um if the genre id is equal to i so i'm
actually getting
an array of genres back from uh from the
filtered movie data
all right so through that from that
array i want to go go through and look
to the genres that i have
and say if that's equal then give me the
name and then join all those names
with uh with a comma otherwise just give
me the data that you have right
so that's what you have to do for genres
that's basically what this is right
so it's saying okay i got all these
numbers but people don't know what
numbers are
right so when i look at the when i look
at the console yeah
of my genres are right i've got
a genre array 28 80 and 53. well i mean
who knows what that is right
who knows what 28 15 53 is right but
that's why you come back here and you
say in the list
i've got this so 28 is action so give me
the name
right of each one and then push it
together
you know join it together with uh with a
comma right so now instead of getting 28
50 53
uh 28 what is that 80 and 53 now i'm
getting action
crime and thriller all right so that
is uh pretty much the entire
app we did we went through uh
we went through the uh error handling
because we actually got an error
but even if we get an error we remove uh
the loader
and then we append with an h2 uh that
there was an error retrieving the data
for that month and year all right so we
actually saw that when we didn't
we didn't put our api key in we actually
got that error
all right so yeah so if you have any
comments
obviously uh any questions about the
code right but it was
pretty simple i mean it works right 20
20 24
a 2014 fam just family movies right
you'll see that
it's only pulling in stuff that has
family obviously stuff that has family
and other stuff but yeah but
at least it has family uh because a lot
of these you know they fit into multiple
multiple genres right so if it's like a
western right you normally your westerns
are
are basic you know like western
animation western comedy
but you get to see you know how this
works uh
you get to learn how to use uh d3 with a
third-party api
um yeah and you get to you know we've
gotten to work with dom manipulation so
it's pretty cool i think d3 uh there's a
lot more power to it and i'm going to
discuss that in the conclusion but
i hope you were able to get something
from this you know just uh yeah work
through the code you're gonna get uh
you're gonna get an opportunity to see
the source code and pull it down and
actually work walk through it
but uh yeah let's i'll see y'all in the
next section
all right welcome to the conclusion of
our d3 basics video
so now we're going to push this code up
to our repository and then you'll have
the link
so that and we'll leave that in the
description so that you can get to the
source code whenever you want alright so
just follow along with me right
get and if you want to add this if
you've been following along in the
tutorial
you can actually uh push this up to your
own repository right so getting it
so we initialize an uh empty git
repository we're going to add
everything right so it should add and
look at the source code editor over here
all right let's see did it add well i'll
just do that
yeah i want to add it i wanted to do it
uh git add
right so yeah get add dot should add
everything right
let's see a window right move okay it's
not adding it all right so we'll just do
this
we'll go all right let's stage the
changes i don't know why i didn't do
that but
all right so we'll do that git commit
minus m first commit
uh so it's putting everything in right
everything that we created
and then we're going to add the remote
and this is our repository all right
you can actually pull that link and then
we're going to push to
the master branch all right so
everything is going up to the master
branch and you'll be able to see it
we're going to leave the link down in
the description all right so that's
going to wrap this video up
now be sure to stay tuned to the
channels like
subscribe comment let us know what you
thought about this video
uh was it too long was it too short do
you need more coding uh whatever it is
just let us know
what we're trying to uh help the
community uh so again we need your
feedback
uh we have some future videos coming up
some of them are gonna use d3 some of
them are gonna use other libraries
uh things a little bit off the beaten
path uh you know that may not be the the
most
um the most uh produced stuff on youtube
we want to try to
uh reach a specific um demographic maybe
some
people who are not using just the
standard you know the standard stuff all
right
so we're actually going to um
be putting those out uh shortly
hopefully by the end of the year so make
sure that you
stay tuned all right and we'll see y'all
on the next one
alright until next time happy coding